[Music]
so just to illustrate the strange
magical mystical ways that the universe
works we've been going back and forth
for a little while trying to schedule
this podcast we met in Nantucket we did
in September as part of the Nantucket
project and and on the day of our
appointed interview actually the day
before I get a text from Tom Scott the
founder of the Nantucket project who
also has happened to be on this podcast
in the past he said I'm in town I want
to meet can we meet on this day the same
day that you're coming over here you as
somebody who's presented at Nantucket
project and asked yeah tomorrow
I have Nadia Bowles whoever coming over
to do the show if somebody I've been
trying to schedule for ever as well who
I met at Nantucket project I don't know
how that happens how does the universe
its convergence and your experience in
all things Devine how do you account for
that and explain that I'm not sure I'm
better anyone else but it was nice to
see Tom today and say hello to Nadia for
me too I will yeah yeah what an amazing
person yes so I'm going back to back
with all of these people who are steeped
in in all things spiritual and in
matters and matters divine so it's cool
to have you here today I've been looking
forward to this conversation for a long
time you have an amazing story so let's
just start at the beginning
hmm paint the picture for me baller
baller lawyer bowler lawyer New York
super successful why you know normal
standards in this country I guess and a
big staff and real estate clients of
note and working 16 hours a day and I
was a normal kid you know yeah I grew up
with my share of droppin in like the
suburbs of New York City I did yeah Long
Island you know and I was
I was a normal kid there partyer uh-huh
you know and tried to stop didn't stop
tried to stop and I made it through high
school in college in law school and kind
of ran that all up did you do the big
law firm thing for a while before he
started your own no no no I was uh
always know I'm always gonna be your own
boss yeah well I was a I was a marketer
from way back I actually sold shoes on
Madison Avenue to put myself through law
school so definitely you got it you you
you know how to put the hustle on a
little bit oh yeah oh yeah you know they
buy the shoes and you stick the shoe
trees in and you up charge them before
they they get to the register either you
know oh yeah are you learning things oh
yeah you make 10% on the shoe trees but
only 2% on the shoes so you have to know
that yeah so work your way through law
school went to law school in Manhattan
him and him and did you start your Pratt
I know that you ultimately you're up in
like Mamaroneck right where you have
your practice but did you start in start
in Manhattan and after about 10 years
there moved it up to Westchester County
and right away I was a big fish in a
small pond you know as opposed to being
lost in Manhattan but like a
transactional lawyer right real estate
deal mostly real estate deals and in
business deals and and I kind of found
myself up there there were a lot of
lifestyle changes I needed needed to
happen and I was flirting with them and
at that point had been sober probably
about five years on your own on my own
and I was in therapy but I wasn't
committed to it I didn't really know
what it was just like I should probably
dial back the partying maybe stop
drinking it was it just was it alcohol
or was it was it something else at that
point there was something else
it was everything actually yeah it was
pretty much everything uh-huh what's
your favorite well if ludes were still
around I'm not sure I'd be sober today
yeah that's what the way of the dodo
unfortunately oh yeah you know so how
was your main thing well it was for that
until you couldn't find him anymore that
would that decade okay yeah I kind of
like rolled through by decade uh-huh so
what did this like early 90s what are we
talking about um and I moved up to
Mamaroneck in 90
mmm-hmm and opened my practice up there
and my biggest client was a big real
estate client I had tens of thousands of
units and I was their general counsel
and then the head of his one of the
divisions and asked me if I wanted to go
across the street and play basketball in
the elementary school that was kind of
across from the headquarters right and
top of the key crossover move ruptured
my Achilles tendon went right down and
called the north Peter
friend of mine and said you're not
touching me unless he'd give me a
prescription for Demerol uh-huh and I
hadn't done I hadn't done anything in
almost five years but it was
instantaneous and my head went right to
that to Demerol right I'd like it in not
morphine not like why dumb had you done
Demerol before probably yeah I like how
you're the one who's prescribing the
pain medication to yourself oh yeah
making the demand oh yeah I made me the
man I am so uh so they did the surgery
and I had the a headed trip because I
had some complications and I had a drip
and so the drip is going for the
morphine and I had hidden the vial of
Demerol under the bedsheets and they
didn't know about it and I always I was
high yeah and that's it I was I was back
on the horse man and that was uh that
lasted ten years I didn't realize that
you had taken a stab at getting sober
prior to John Achilles incident yeah
but without a 12-step or anything like
that it's kind of like your own therapy
white-knuckle do-it-yourself version
well I went to a therapist in the city
who was very helpful didn't lead me to a
a or a psychiatry at that point but he
was I learned a lot from him and and I
stayed clean for quite a while and I
thought I would always be clean yeah I
didn't you know I didn't no idea how
but then this injury it's the perfect
opportunity for no one's gonna say
anything oh yeah it was a lawyer you
know you can get what you need it was a
lawyer's dream you know except I was the
one who went down right and walk me
through how you know that initial fix
with Demerol ends up snowballing into
basically a full-time habit well I had
friends who were doctors and you know I
was it was a kind of a professional Club
and none of them probably knew at first
that they were contributing to something
that was more dangerous although every
one of them kind of said the same thing
to me you know just be careful or and I
guess they didn't want me to stop
breathing on their watch yeah but
meanwhile still writing the script mm
every two or three did you have to I
mean I've I've heard crazy stories from
lots of friends of mine who you know
have navigated this world and the links
to which they would go I got doctor
friends you know get hooked on fentanyl
and things like that and like they just
tell the most elaborate stories about
how they're able to whether they're
stealing scrip pads or you know even
doctors who are falsifying their own
scripts yeah how they would rotate which
pharmacies they would go to and they
knew the shifts of who's gonna be behind
the counter at a certain time like all
this shenanigans to make sure that they
would be able to cop there was a little
bit of that but mostly they they just
wanted free legal work right and so so
that that was it yeah there was quid pro
quo there for sure Wow you know and and
the other thing I found out is that I
possessed all their secrets I was all
their lawyer I was a lawyer uh-huh so
you know the they had a vested interest
in keeping me right well that's a very
interesting devil's bargain well I
didn't know that I didn't even realize
how manipulative I was being you know I
I wasn't interested I just wanted the
drugs right I didn't really understand
any of that at the time and was it
always Demerol or did that morph into
oxy another thing well after or six or
seven years or so and
the change was pretty imperceptible from
a day-to-day basis you know there was it
was hard to be able to fit there's no
way I could have figured it out but you
know if you had looked at me kind of in
a a kind of time of two years or three
years you would have seen massive
changes of personality and of weight and
I blown up to 200 and maybe five pounds
at one point and you know just kind of
like the the pores open of someone who
was continually going through withdrawal
yeah and then and instead of that clammy
power oh yeah yeah I look like Luca
Brasi well the other interesting thing
and I think it's important to point this
out just to be completely you know kind
of intellectually honest about the whole
thing is that in the first phase of this
your your law practice blossoms right
because you become kind of this
unqualified eed like you're able to
aggressively pursue these deals without
fear like it kind of masks all of these
things that hold us back in certain
respects and I think you know that's
what initially hooks the drug addict in
because it works for a while until it
stops working well it was a disinhibitor
for sure and I was willing to take on a
lot of risk and and so things were
flying I mean it was it was it was a go
go go and it was the run-up to the
dot-com boom and some of my clients were
offering me pieces of their companies in
exchange for legal services and you know
other kind of cycle I had you know
uh-huh and and and then at some point I
stopped being able to show up yeah and
it was getting it was getting pretty
tense and I had a client who had hurt
himself and badly him maybe and he had
neck surgery and it was it was ugly and
he walked into my office one day and you
know he suspected what was going on with
me a little bit and he just dumped a
handful of oxycontin
on my on my desk and he had a limitless
supply and because he could back then
and that was it I mean there was a
tipping point where there was no there
was no return from no wow so that guy
was like the ultimate enabler he knew he
knew you were doing this and he knew you
had a problem and he's like here's your
unlimited supply why he wanted a friend
uh-huh and he wanted someone there was
no question you know and and four days I
you know I didn't go to work I sat in
his den and we watched the Golf Channel
and right and in the zoo doubt you know
it was it was on so no one showing up to
work well I wasn't showing up where the
people who worked for me they were
concerned but I didn't understand that
and and I and what I've learned since
hell how much undiagnosed bipolar
disorder you know that I had back then
and and how I was really self-medicating
and and it had been bad my whole life I
just didn't really know because I had
been medicated in one way or another
who out just in your own way through
partying trying to yeah trying to quiet
yeah mostly maddening have you had so
you've had manic episodes oh yeah what
does that feel like
um just great yeah you know that's
that's why people that have bipolar
don't want to be medicated right yeah I
mean I've always since I was diagnosed
in and that that had certainly was a
concurrent with my fall
I've been hyper vigilant but I I would
go through phases kind of where I was
semi normal mm-hmm and then I would get
super smart and be able to solve see
connections other people couldn't see
and solve all kinds of problems and then
slide into megalomania uh-huh and so I
would have a doctor for example clients
who wanted a way to put his business
together and then in the same
conversation
ten minutes later I'm talking to him
about opening up ten offices instead of
one and he
look at me like I'm crazy like you know
we're having enough problem with one you
know like what's this about and then
inevitably the the the crash would
happen yeah and I'd fall into depression
it's almost like cocaine talk yeah right
oh yeah very much is it the most the
most accurate representation that I've
ever seen in media like in narrative
media is is the character in homeland
did you watch that oh yeah oh yeah cuz
her episode seemed to be from what I
understand of the disease to be the most
kind of naturalistic and realistic
compared to what it's actually like when
I saw some of her manic episodes and it
refreshed my my recollection of some of
the things I did and people are right
people around me knew I mean I had of
course yeah but I didn't know and I'm
not my staff wouldn't line up at my
office store and which would be closed
and my my assistant was outside and they
would be checking in with her like where
I was on the on the sine curve and psych
her and and if I was in and if I was
being smart or I was being crazy right
and you know they they know but I I
didn't huh yeah well we have a
chalkboard here you want to start
writing equations down and pinning our
pictures yeah how many does it does it
work like that where you're you're up
all night like brainstorming solving the
universe's problems it did yeah it did
no not not anymore yeah but it took a
lot of years of medication trials and
things like that to figure it out but
what's it like when you pour Demerol or
oxycontin on top of that was that
mixture translated well I mean that you
know that was pretty sober if ik you
know so that that kind of brought me
down out of my mania for the most part
but you know the the bouncing up and
down was was the worst thing that could
possibly happen yeah as was the stress
of being in that kind of a law firm too
so I I didn't know what's going on at
home with your wife I don't know I don't
know I mean
she claims that you know my this my
ex-wife she you know she claims that she
didn't know and I believe her because I
was just this big gregarious you know
personality you know back-slapping
personality and we and people you know
made a lot of you know because the money
was there and the personality was there
people made a lot of company a lot big
wide swath but I'm sure behind my Jeff
will take care of it don't worry about
it I was a I was a guy back then a thick
I was a fixer mm-hm
but I'm not sure that that's a good term
anymore
but back then not like in the Michael
Clint
Clayton myself latex are not the Michael
Cohen fixer right yeah I guess but you
know Michael clay I mean he's you know
hitting the poker games and doing a lot
of kind of underground stuff too
yeah is that part of your lifestyle also
well you know I might have thought I was
like George Clooney but probably not
really so the wheels are progressively
falling off the wagon but really the the
life changer is a couple lines that you
crossed yeah you can't really ever take
back no no so walk me up to those points
well I mean the firm started to decay
and I didn't really know it and the day
came when we ran out of cash and it
wasn't a large amount really and there's
a lot of things I could have done with a
phone call button Ted instead I told my
office manager to move some money out of
the client escrow account and into the
operating account and she looked at me
like I was crazy I mean I remember the
conversation you know like is this you
sure this is something you want to do
and I said yeah to do it and you know it
was just a couple clicks on Sebring was
open and problem solved for the day and
I had no idea that that was the
beginning of the end
yeah
ya know but unsung you knew it was a
no-no oh yeah you knew yeah yeah yeah
but you know so water so were the drugs
you know I mean it was just part of that
pathology was just playing out the
decision-making yeah yeah yeah is not so
good at this point no I was I was you
know I can't blame it on anything other
than I don't blame it on the drugs you
know but I certainly I wasn't fully
aware of what the consequences were
going to be so life altering and so
permanent well part and parcel of being
an addict is an inability to ask for
help right so are you trying to solve
this prophetic that has to do with being
a lawyer then raise my hand and say hey
look I have a problem here like I can't
meet payroll can somebody help me out
okay
me too admit weakness and that's for
whatever reason very difficult for
somebody who's in the throes of
addiction yeah well I also I wasn't
gonna get caught I mean there was you
know this was something right right this
oh these girls oh yeah oh yeah you're
sure oh yeah
and and I can I'll put it back tomorrow
which I did and then the day after
tomorrow came and I did it again and it
became a wallet it became for our for
our firm right once you do it once then
it becomes easy to do it again yeah
there's no question again yeah
and where does this all catch up to you
um started there was an investigation
that started through the ethics
committee the grievance committee and
over something small and I had a higher
ethics lawyers and I was being
investigated and there were a lot of
interviews and and I thought I was doing
well and I thought that maybe I was
going to slide through it because I'm
sure that was denial but I had no point
that I think that my career was over and
I was taking in new clients and then
9/11 happened
and I just felt everything fall out from
under me just there was like my every
sense of safety or structure or just
went in that moment and I became a
madman and clients started just clients
started to shrivel up and within a
couple of months there was a there were
ads on the radio and on TV for
businesses that businesses that had been
adversely affected by 9/11 and in truth
I didn't know if it was the drugs or
9/11 or what but I was sitting there
with a shattered firm and I called up
the SBA Small Business Administration
that was advertising for of businesses
to get in touch with them and I asked
them I told my story and they told me I
would qualify and they sent me an
application and I filled it out and I
just couldn't help myself but to
embellish that application and claim I
had a office that was a block away from
Ground Zero mm-hmm and and I didn't need
to do it so you write up this
application that you have a Manhattan
office exactly down in the Wall Street
area exact action Trump's building at
4100 you were that specific oh yeah oh
yeah oh no you had to be specific and in
truth and so easily verified but enjoy
and truth I had a conference room
relationship with a law firm there and
so that address was on my letterhead oh
I see so there is okay all right but but
there was no economic and you were never
really going there right I'd never been
there
uh-huh and there was it and there was no
economic effect of having lost that off
to sunlight on me or my firm and and and
and I I embellished that I actually had
right so you get this loan it's like 200
grand
yeah 247 247 thousand dollars yeah which
alleviates your need to dip into the
client trust account I would imagine
that's also drying up because the
clients are running for the hills
because you're a lunatic oh yeah yeah
yeah and your staff is down to a
skeleton crew at this point huh at some
point I I figured out that this was not
going in a good direction and I made
arrangements for all my staff and all my
files and everything to to go to another
law firm and so for the last three or
four months before before I hit my
bottom I was pretty much alone in that
office uh-huh
what's interesting is you hit your
bottom and you get you get sober before
the chickens come home to roost well
before on the loan thing right what what
precipitates your bottom well what
happened was I am a business associate
of mine that I had treated badly in the
couple of years before he wound up
preparing an affidavit or a letter
lengthy one detailing everything I had
done wrong had done to him including my
my opioid abuse and things like that and
all kinds of other things and my ethics
attorney became aware of it sent me a
copy and I read it and I called him up
and I said is this it I mean are we done
and he said yeah you're pretty much done
there's just nothing we Kiwi can do from
here
so I said not in terms of being trihard
yeah exactly trying to defend my law
license yeah so I said to him all right
why don't you just resign my law license
for me and I went to my doctor friend
and I got a prescription of Demerol
you know 40 tabs and went home
and after my wife and ex-wife and kids
went to sleep I I took the whole vial
it's like 40 tabs yeah yeah and yeah I
knew what I was doing and I was trying
to kill myself
was it a was it a real suicide attempt
or was it a desperate call for help I
mean 40 seems like enough but your
tolerance must have been insane
my tolerance was insane but I don't
think I thought 40 would be enough that
was the point
I thought 40 would be enough and and
I've spent a lot of years trying to
figure out whether or not it was a real
attempt or cry for help but I wanted the
noise in my head to stop there was like
no way and and and just what you know
what the what the price to pay I didn't
understand it you know I just knew that
everything that I had and this this this
life in this house and the cars and the
and the prestige and and at that point I
was on the local school board and I
owned health clubs and I owned real and
I owned real estate and it was all like
a restaurant owned a restaurant huh yeah
I was you know I was one of those guys
yeah and I knew it was all gonna tumble
down it was gonna tumble down anyway
yeah you know buddy whoa but uh but I
knew it was gonna tumble then so uh I
took it and it's interesting that that I
mean I can see that it was a real
attempt in the sense that you kind of
calmly relinquished all of it like
you're like just like let go of might
like you just let it all go rather than
fight it yeah there was a there's a
giving up in that where it's like it's
it's done I'm it's done it was actually
the least dramatic part of the of those
10 years probably it was just it was the
feather on the on the scale you just
landed and that was it just go do what I
gotta do and that was it with addicts
there's also there also tends to be a
narcissism in these attempts looks like
now I'm gonna you know I'm this is how
I'm gonna go out and people are gonna
say oh poor Jeff you know like there's
was a part of that thinking oh I
definitely was I definitely was you know
wanted to know how many people were
gonna show up at my funeral right you
know that kind of thinking yeah you know
no but I'd been thinking that for a long
time
uh there was though
you know I I didn't I didn't know if I I
didn't know what if there was anything
of myself left at that point did you
have a conscious awareness of how you
would then be been the architect of your
own destruction what were you in a
victim mentality of everyone's out to
get you and you're just doing what you
need to do to survive and why is this
happening to me it was like I had
clarity at that point yeah because I it
wasn't like I was I was clear clear and
then took that vial of drugs I was
probably stoned already right so it was
a it was probably a victim mentality and
they're sure you know like you know
everything was my parents fault kind of
thing uh-huh
and so how do you not die after taking
40 Demerol by yeah I think you hit it I
had a huge tolerance but I woke up in
the floor and in the morning
and I vomited all over myself and you
know I didn't go kind of the Jimi
Hendrix way you woke up on your own or
did your why no no I woke up on my own I
was it was pretty early and and I knew
we're in the kitchen we had some more we
would have had some more things I could
take and I kind of crawled to the
kitchen I remember wasting myself up to
try to get it and I realized I had taken
them too I mean and and so then there
was the there was a trip to the you know
a couple of days later I actually I
actually detox I didn't go to the
hospital but a few days later I I called
the silver Hill Hospital in New Canaan
and I wanted to go there I knew to go
there because clients of mine who had
the okie he'd went there they went so
you made a decision like I'm done and
and you did your own self-styled detox
at home well he done it on versed I had
done it a hundred times before so it
wasn't as if I was ignorant of what a
withdrawal would be like this was just
the super one
this is the biggest one I've ever been
through and certainly the first one I
overtly tried to kill myself opiate
withdrawal is gnarly it was bad it was
bad and how long did it go on for three
or four days probably it was bad so you
waited until you've weathered that
before you checked yourself into
treatment
oh yeah III because I was I knew better
than anybody I was you didn't want to
you didn't want to look like going
to treatment oh no no I mean yeah oh but
you know what happens with people who
have a lot of experience in these things
you become kind of like a med professor
of drugs you know you know I was like I
had a mercs manual and a and a PDR there
and you know so I knew my drugs and were
you doing it
total cold turkey or we're all turning
yourself out yeah no I was not that was
the problem right you know I was I was
going through all the physical
manifestations it was bad but then not
and but I knew that that was it ended so
you had a sense that this as somebody
who tried to get sober many times on
your own yeah you know what it's like
it's like okay this time I'm never gonna
do it again but kind of in the back your
head you're like you're not really sold
on the idea but this was qualitatively
different you know well every other time
it was two hours or uh-huh two days
later I was back at it but something was
different here this was well I didn't
have a life to go back to I knew that
you know I knew everything was gone I
didn't I didn't really understand it all
at that point the gift of a hard bottom
you know that's something I learned
later but everything was gone and and so
going to rehab going was yeah it was a
blessing and you were in rehab for like
seven weeks or something like that yeah
I mean I yeah yeah I'm I I remember I
was about first day I go to the acute
care unit where they put people who were
danger to themselves or who could OD or
and could die from detox or whatever
and then five days later I got moved to
a step-down facility and clear of all
those opiates I've been taking I started
to have amazing awarenesses of what I
had done and all this victim ization
that I had been going through my whole
life and and I started to see things
this the first little pieces of of
clarity started coming through well that
could also provoke quite a bit of
anxiety without your medication to
buffer the impact of that truth landing
on you like wow my whole life is
decimated well they had already started
me on bipolar med to the point I mean
they I'm I got diagnosed pretty fast and
so there was a whole different kind of
haze I was in for a while I was
adjusting a Thorazine shuffle a little
bit yeah one cooked one flew over the
cuckoo's never told this before but I
have but I um I wandered into the creek
at the rehab and they found me just
walking through the creek in the water
and you know like like a guy in his
bathrobe in the creek right that kind of
image gonna get Michael clean he wanted
off the reservation you know so I had a
in his bathrobe yeah yeah yeah and and
in a few weeks before I hit my bottom of
course I had to go out and at least the
brand-new BMW 7-series yeah of course
because you know I was that insane
so I driven that car up to the rehab so
it's sitting there like as a you know
it's a testimony in my old life and I
barely look at it and and and so there's
a whole story how I got rid of that car
which is amazing too but but I knew that
I just couldn't go back there that for
sure
so how do you begin to piece your life
back together in the aftermath of all of
this well certainly through recovery I
mean seven weeks in rehab and they
brought recovery meetings in and I kind
of took to them and more I think to the
structure then to anything I was I was
too out of it to learn anything I was
gone and on the first day out of rehab I
did what I was I was told to do I showed
up at the meeting and I raised my hand
and I said I'm Jeff and I'm an alcoholic
and a drug addict than I needed
temporary sponsor mm-hmm and I gave you
know like three seconds on on my drug of
choice or I can't remember right now but
at the end of the meeting the the leader
who had been leading the meeting and I
thought it was the the boss right I
didn't know I was my first meeting I
didn't know and he came up to me and he
said you know this is for alcoholics and
you've done drugs and you're in the
wrong meeting and how dare that guy say
that yeah I've never heard anybody say
anything like that well you're a West
Coast guy yeah
that's interesting Wow and this other
guy came up to me who was standing right
there and he was the spitting image of
Freddie Mercury I am telling you this
guy I thought it was Freddie Mercury in
my haze and he said to me um don't don't
mind that don't mind that guy I'll be
your temporary sponsor and Brian T was
my my sponsor and he gave me very clear
instructions you know like you know what
to do and for 30 60 days I went to a
noon meeting every day and I fell asleep
and with my head against the wall
because I couldn't even focus but you
showed up I showed on took direction yep
made yourself known yep and again to
take accountability did all that stuff
that seems completely unrelated to
staying sober like
yeah I was just lucky bold numbers make
coffee Lyle I keep coming back yeah
exactly
and but we had to get rid of the house
and we had and of course I did what
every you have no income at this point
no income at this point yeah and a
little you know some savings but no
income and I did what every sane guy
does when they lose their house in their
career and their reputation I moved to
Greenwich the one of the wealthiest
communities in one giant why would you
do that
um because I had started going to a a
meetings there the recovery meetings
there and I those meetings were so
important to me that I had to be there
and also it was only six miles from our
home and although the the state line is
is huge in terms of media and in terms
of interconnectivity but my I figured my
kids would still be able to maintain
relationships with their friends mm-hmm
and that that was true that had that
happen but there we were in Greenwich
and for the next 20 months or so I was
living in an apartment and Greenwich and
going to meetings and I went three times
a day four times a day sometimes and I
was a lock step you know in recovery
that did that was my life and this saves
your life saved my life yeah absolutely
it's interesting to me I'm always
encouraged when I hear stories like
yours of people who whose lives have
been spared as a result of the 12 steps
because in our fast-paced modern culture
it seems like every year there's some
new hot take on what sobriety is should
be and now we know more about addiction
and alcoholism than we ever have before
and all these other ideas are antiquated
and you know maybe there's truth in that
maybe there's not but I know that
12-step and Alcoholics Anonymous saved
my life it's saved it's saved a lot of
so many people that I know
and it works you know if your yeah I
never know I have no opinion on how
people get so yeah they find other ways
of doing that more power to them I just
know that this is what has worked for me
and continues to work for me and me and
and remains my number one priority
well it's a big world and I assume
there's people getting sober other way
yes parts for me it worked
mm-hmm and it gave me a home you know
family people who I weren't judging me
and and I had abandoned all my people
places and things because nobody would
talk to me I was a pariah and so I
didn't have the places I didn't have the
things and I didn't have the people so
that hard bottom was a blessing yeah and
it had to you know forced you to
right-size your ego and take stock in
the inventory of how you were living and
figure out a new approach to how you
were going to get through the day
yeah inch by inch you know big thoughts
like that probably didn't happen for a
while you know I was just trying to
survive but little little did you know
that you had another bottom waiting
waiting for you it was the Lord danced
right so I was sober about 20 months and
I got a koala on my cell phone from two
investigators from the government I
remember them as FBI agents but in
retrospect they were probably from an
another government division and they
told me that I had a there was a warrant
out for my arrest in connection with
that that that loan and I I had no idea
I mean I tell you I was complete denial
I mean I had done my I'd done my ninth
step I'm at my eighth step my nice step
and I wrote down everyone who I had
harmed and what my wrongs were and there
were 136 names on that list and not the
government huh
had you made payments on that loan or
repaid it no no so you you even eat
setting aside the fact that it was a
it was a fraudulent loan you had
defaulted on it as well
oh yeah sure but it still didn't make
your nine-nine step I had no idea that's
a big blind spot yeah well I that's as
it turns out that's it's not uncommon
yeah no no I'm not listening I'm not no
I've done you know I've done analogous
things so the man I thought I was you
know on the on the mend here well it had
a 30-year repayment schedule so I
thought I had in some crazy I died 30
years to repay or something I don't
really know what bid it was I'm noting
flip about it I'm just I got this I had
no idea what's right so you're like wait
what that loan and I mean where they
like get in the back of the suburban or
no no I mean I was certainly conscious
enough in that conversation to ask them
I asked them well you know what do you
want me to do yeah you want to come get
me over to you and want to give me some
time to come down I've been a lawyer for
a long time and they said by two weeks
you know I said I'll go hire a lawyer
I'll come down and I did and so two
weeks later I had to appear at the u.s.
courthouse at the 500 Pearl Street in
Manhattan and I hadn't been down there
since 9/11 so when I got down there it
was still look like a war zone and with
the barricades in the checkpoints and
and and military with with machine guns
and things in front of in front of
buildings and I was going into this
situation and I couldn't have felt worse
it was you know it's like and and I knew
that my my crime was you know having
taken advantage of an economic benefit
relating to 9/11 and it was searing you
know it was just it was it was there was
nothing I could do you know I I wanted I
wanted to get high but
there was no way I was gonna ever go
back and so was the first time I was
ever handcuffed and put in a Cell and to
my arraignment and and did you plead
guilty or did you try to fight this um
no I don't remember what happened at my
arraignment to be honest I just know
that I was released without a bond and I
had a I would be sentenced at some point
in the in the future and were you
released on your own recognizance so you
could go home before I went to
sentencing and I got ya and then it took
two years to get sentenced oh really oh
my god so you have to live with the
looming inevitability that you might be
going to jail for two years and where
that reality and in the hope that I
wouldn't and in the and the reason I
went to jail probably oh the reason I
went to prison was no judge was not no
judge is gonna give a an on confining
sentence to someone who is crime was
somehow related to 9/11 not in that
climate there was it just couldn't have
right taking advantage of sign 11 for
your own personal gain exactly is there
anything more reprehensible in a civil
yeah and and and he said that from
during the sentencing he said that you
know that at the same time because I had
been in recovery and had and had done a
lot of service and had spawn season and
had 50 letters of recommendation and
everyone and the room was packed with
people from Greenwich recovery he'd get
down his character witnesses yeah he
downward he downward departed me so I
had a a lower a lesser sentence than I
otherwise would have had yeah so what
was the sentence
18 months 15 months no what what did you
what was the sentence short of short of
all of those character witnesses showing
up what do you think he would have hit
you with um it could have been anywhere
from 21 to 28 as I recall something like
that yeah so um I was
once I was happy with the 18 months I
mean I was expecting something but there
was a huge sense of relief that went
along with the with a fear like this
phase is over I don't it could have been
delayed and delayed and my family was in
just because now you know what you're
contending with yeah yeah and so three
or four three or four months later no
maybe two months later I had a report to
prison Allenwood low-security prison out
in Pennsylvania and I had been told that
I was gonna go to you know Club fed yeah
to a camp where where white-collar guys
go and I had a security level of zero I
read a lot of books play some tennis
yeah sure of course okay and and I had
read at that point I had read a lot of
books on on confinement and I had read
Mandela and Bonhoeffer and and men
search for meeting Viktor Frankl and a
lot of things that kind of put me in
that headspace where I know what I'm
wearing for this yeah and and because at
that point I'd been sober almost four
years there's no doubt that was the
biggest influence on me in terms of
making it part of my recovery but I
found out that I was designated to a
low-security prison with bars and
controlled movements and and you know
walls and dogs and fences and razor wire
what happened like no vacancy at the
Country Club
it's exactly what it was on the day I
was designated shits that you could call
in and I tried from the Michael Clayton
days I know I tried it I tried act
actually I like I know a guy there's the
guy you call no I hired a prison
consultant who took money from me
there's guys that I didn't even know
that there was such a thing of course
yeah it's a sub industry for everything
yeah and he took money from me and and
then did nothing he's supposed to broker
this machole that a change of
designation yes as it turns out like
five years or six years later there was
a
a special on Dateline or 20/20 one of
their shows and he was the subject of of
one of those episodes where he was
wanted for murder
oh so it was that's dark all right it's
a Michael Clayton you got I mean
like this guy's probably you know I'm a
speed dial of a lot of hedge fund
managers and guys like that who are in
the crosshairs of the feds oh there's a
whole story yeah but you know I I hadn't
heard a word about the guy in all those
years I like pointed at the TV and I
didn't do anything and I and um and I
don't know if I was remarried at that
point but I said tool in my I said to
live my wife I said that's the guy
that's the guy you know so no Country
Club for you know but still minimum
security but was it filled with like
more violent offenders or were they all
like some white-collar financial no
offenders there were there were 1500
inmates on that compound and there were
five former stockbrokers two former
doctors one former lawyer that was me
and the other 1500 were drug dealers and
violent criminals and that's just the
way it was that's gotta make for an
interesting social dynamic yeah I mean
it was nothing I knew about and back
then it wasn't like it is now where
there's a lot of information out there
and on the internet and there's a lot of
resources to be able to pull from and we
were alone I was I had no information
going in huh and and I walked in the
door and I was handcuffed and strip
searched and and as again another divine
moment my sentencing judge had made a
mistake on my report date so I reported
on Easter Sunday and when we got up
there there was no intake people I mean
it was Easter Sunday so I was actually I
was actually admitted by the
the head lieutenant of the entire
compound and he was standing there was a
cut with a clipboard and looking pretty
fierce and I was naked and he said to me
so you're the lawyer and I said no I
used to be and I didn't know that was
exactly the right answer huh you know I
was I was there was the riots a test
like is this guy gonna cause problems
for me well yeah he wanted to know if I
was if I was gonna be making money off
other inmates and if I was had a hustle
going and I have things I knew nothing
about you know I just I was you know I
was just showing up and trying to tell
the truth and what's the day-to-day
reality in a place like that versus what
we might know only from movies or
television well if you take oranged is
the new black for example there's an
example of a pretty low security prison
and you take everything that happens
there in one episode if you spread that
out over a year - uh-huh that's pretty
much what happens in a prison everything
happens it just happens on a different
timeline a more expansive mostly it's
people sitting around reading doing very
little you go to work you work for three
or four hours you come back there's not
that much drama you don't have to form
alliances for protection you know maybe
if I was younger at the time I was 48
years old and maybe if I was a young
buck and part of the pecking order or if
I was a gang guy or something it might
have been different but mostly I was
left alone but just like if you worked
in any you know if anybody who works in
a sea of cubicles in a foursome company
you know it's the humdrum existence I
imagine you know I never I never did
that but you show up and you do your
work but when something exciting happens
something exciting happens in prison
when something exciting happens it's
it's dangerous yeah yeah it's dangerous
and I saw some things I never
I would see like the shanks and the
lockdowns and my only point of reference
is what I see on the tube yeah well I I
mean I I saw I saw a couple of people
get killed
hmm and it was really really frightening
and it was surreal
you know I I couldn't really believe
what I was seeing like I'd never seen
people behave that way and and it was
fast and very very fast and it's very
violent and you stay sober I stayed
sober
was there a and there was a a there was
na and there were classes I had to take
because for substance abuse classes and
the a a was remarkable in there because
it was mostly inner-city guys and when I
first got there because I had four years
of sobriety on the street when I got to
the a a meeting there was there were
guys who who we went around the room and
they and they introduced themselves in
their day count or their year count and
there were guys who were reporting that
they had three four or five years of
sobriety but their sentences were longer
than that so they were getting stoned in
prison yeah and not one person in that
room had ever spent one day clean on the
street and and they were fascinated you
know buddy so that makes you that gives
you some stature I guess right like as
somebody who has an experience that they
don't have well it was certainly a trade
going on I mean the trade going on was
that you know they taught me how to stay
sober in prison and the the greatest
fear they had was going back out on the
street and being tempted quickly by
women drugs whatever yeah cause you're
no longer in a controlled environment
right oh yeah well this is the first
sense of community that most of them
have ever had in their lives you know
you don't realize even if how much
isolation people live in and this was
that I mean people don't really know
what it's like in a prison I mean
there's a there's a
it's a family in a way of the
white-collar criminals that were in this
prison how many of them were there in
some way related directly or indirectly
to drugs and alcohol like how were their
offenses kind of intertwined with
drinking and using um I think that a
hundred percent of them but yeah I don't
I don't know that they were drug crimes
but you know but but just massive part
here judge oh yo yeah oh yeah for sure
yeah yeah for sure and you do the whole
18 months I did thirteen and a half
months and then I came out to a halfway
house and then to a home confinement and
I lived with a friend in Connecticut for
a few months until my sentence was over
and then I started three years of
federal probation and the first wife
when does she split I was kicked out I
you I was kicked out when did that
happen
that was right right that was prison
there that was right after I got um I
got arrested up so that was back in 2004
and she for good reason she was wrong
you know she was right yeah what's your
relationship with her now you talk to
her at all yeah it's it's it's civil um
it's civil you know I I hurt her I hurt
her I hurt my children
it took a lot of years to reform
relationships with my children how old
are your kids now
um thirty four and thirty and I have
three grandchildren and one on the way
and I didn't know if I would ever see
them I didn't but things are better now
so you get out of prison you're in
halfway houses sober living mm-hmm
trying to figure out how you're gonna
make your way in the world without being
able to do the one thing you know how to
do to make a living
yeah apart from it yeah and but I had a
drug and alcohol caster
I was also also in my sentence I had to
go to one year of drug and alcohol
counseling after
and it just so happens he was a ex
priest who became a ex Catholic priest
who became a drug and alcohol counselor
and he asked me what are you gonna do
and I was a product of recovery so I
said well I'm gonna go to recovery and
I'm gonna have spawn seized and I'm
gonna do my thing and he said my job is
they yeah my job as a a and he said to
me well maybe it's a good idea to do
some things that you can put on a resume
and that was like a aha moment huh
and so like oh yeah resume I never
really had a brezin made before so I
called up silver Hill and I told him my
story that I've been to prison and I
want to come volunteer there and they
told me to come right over because I
happened to be in the area and I went
over there and I sat down with him and
we talked for a while and they told me
that they wanted me to become a
volunteer and they made me feel out of
an application and they were gonna do a
background check and I wasn't quite sure
what the background check was about cuz
I told them everything that yeah but of
course that's their per that a process
and I left there thinking if I can't get
a volunteer job in my own rehab how am I
ever gonna be able to do anything but I
got a call from them two hours later and
they and they said told me I could start
mm-hmm and and I I collated paper I did
stapling I did whatever I did whatever
and worked my way through to more and
more responsibility there and where does
Divinity School enter the picture well
um I was I was volunteering in a couple
different places for a couple of years
and it became clear that I wanted to be
in in a helping profession and the kind
of like when I first started wanted to
be a lawyer I thought it was a helping
profession I didn't realize you know how
much the money would
would subsume all that and and I didn't
know what I wanted to do so I went to
see a pastor at the church and I was
Jewish it didn't time I do I don't think
we said that again I was I was I was
gonna get to that how does this Jewish
guy and uh you know becoming a reverend
well you know there's a transformation
that happens you know not just in
recovery you know you know that I mean
you know you kind of find God or at
least many people do I did but in prison
there's no question that I I was
embracing a different form of theology
that I really understood and but I
hadn't converted I hadn't been baptized
at that point and so I went to the
pastor in the church that Lynn and I
were going to and I told him that I want
to do something I want to do something
meaningful and he said why don't you
consider going to seminary and I had no
idea what that I mean I mean I really
I'm a nice Jewish kid from Long Island
yeah and I but I thought summer is where
monks walked around the hoods and all
and he said no it's a it's a progressive
seminary and you know it was a place
where you learned about social justice
and that resonated with me so I applied
and I had to write down my to tell my
story for the from you know really for
the first time in writing and I had no
illusions that I was going to get
admitted to the seminary on but a little
while didn't take that long and I got
admitted and so Union Theological
Seminary and it's in Morningside Heights
up it's it's a part of the Columbia
right University family yeah when you
were practicing law and using and just
you know doing you live in the Michael
Clayton life what was your relationship
to spirituality then
I was a I was a cultural Jew not
certainly not a religious or an
observant one but my thing you know my
daughter's had been bat Mitzvahed and we
showed up to show lon
hi holy days but you know I'd abandoned
all of that I mean there's no question
that once I got into into drugs that any
any shred of spirituality had it was it
was gone
so then when you find yourself in
treatment and in 12-step you have to you
know reconnect with that aspect yeah who
you are and one of the things that that
you know people who are struggling or
who are suffering find difficult is is
this concept of of God that's kind of
packed into 12-step yeah alienating for
a lot of people they're like look I know
I need to get sober I got to stop
drinking or using like this whole God
business like it's just not for me so
I'm just gonna find another way yeah
yeah well for me it was you know it
wasn't quite a guy with a white beard
but there's no I was connecting to the
god of my childhood for sure you know
some omnipotent omnipresent being you
know there's an anthropomorphic aspect
to it but certainly I II I was praying I
was on my knees praying to something and
and it was forming you know it was
forming as I as I kind of went through
the next few years and how did that
evolve like what does that look for it
look like for you now um well now I
myself a double belong er you know since
that man I mean I'm Jewish and I'm a
Christian uh-huh and that was a phrase
coined by Paul knitter who was one of my
professors at Union Theological who um
who was a Christian and Buddhist
and do that yeah that you know word
there's no rules and and and in truth
you know so much of it is about how we
live and how we behave and living in
right thinking and right action and
right intent and you know these are our
Buddhist ideological tenets within the
you know within the the Eightfold Path
and all of that you know and I didn't
know that at the time really I just knew
that there was some kind of commonality
but I definitely needed a theology of
looking forward of transformation and of
rebirth and I found that in in
Christianity when you're in Divinity
School
are you exposed to these different
modalities or is a very Christian
oriented no this is the most liberal
progressive seminary in the world I mean
this is I got introduced to all kinds of
things I had never been around and and I
was the you know I was the minority
there because it was the it was um
feminist and womanist and gay and
transgender and and the beautiful people
all of mostly who came out of some kind
of suffering and and we're finding
themselves in in religion and faith and
service and it was it was the school of
Bonhoeffer and the Niebuhr and so it had
a and James cone and black liberation
theology so it had a very it was steeped
in social justice and but I was the
oddball out I mean it was then they were
it was Occupy Wall Street and I was one
of the one-percenters you know I mean I
yes you're like twice as old as everyone
yeah I'm more than twice as all of the
youth mentioned before we were recorded
that you lived in the door for a while
fair enough for a while I was coming
down from Greenwich every day and taking
metro-north down into 125th Street yeah
for a little while
we took a place in the dorm
um mostly because I couldn't keep up
with the work I hadn't been I'd been out
of law school for almost 30 years at
that point and I just couldn't do the
reading it was massive much I found it
much harder than what much Wow
and are you employed at the rehab at
this point like do you have any income
or yeah yeah well I'm up in grow well in
that first year it was probably was a
little tough yeah but then I was up in
Bridgeport and and I was doing re-entry
work and so living in Greenwich and
going to school in Manhattan and taking
the train up to Bridgeport and and and
trying to work my way through the issues
of why I was in seminary to begin with
because that wasn't abundantly clear and
for a while I hid my background from
everyone because I didn't want to be
known as the prison guy I didn't want
that moniker on me but at some point I I
knew I was having an inauthentic
experience if I wasn't actually being
honest about what my background was what
was informing my work and informing my
papers and things like that and once I
did that then everything just broke open
was there where he blocked out of fear
of being judged or what was the
impediment to you just owning that
aspect of why you were there I think
that was that and and also that I was so
busy that I I was going to very few AAA
meetings very and so I was sliding
backwards you know into into kind of a
more selfish I was in seminary
ironically but feeling self more selfish
and and and the awareness came to me at
some point there that it's not about
what I get from it it's what I put into
it which I had known from right from AAA
but for some reason they don't daily
reminder exactly and what's that have
you're not a charge yourself well needs
to be sublimated yes
so the polarity changed in and I got
through it and and it was a beaut
all day when we when I graduated and you
know and where does shame enter into all
of this like what is your relationship
to that how have you you know weathered
that aspect of your past um
it's better now mostly but on any given
day I could wake up in and and the
specter is there you know just
everything it could be overwhelming and
certainly service has changed all that
you know being helpful to others and and
seeing my and identify denting with
their stories and and and little by
little I was able to move through and
you know shame you know shame is guilt
is about what you did and shame is about
who you are and I was able to navigate
that at some point but it probably took
a decade yeah I was it was hard yeah I
find that were harder on ourselves then
then others are and our community is
more willing to forgive us than we are
willing to forgive ourselves oh that's
true it makes sense yeah and I could see
the change manifesting and my friends
and the people around me but I'm but I
couldn't see the change in their trust
slowly my answer would help with your
community yeah yeah yeah but was that
part of not wanting to share your story
with your peers and in in Divinity
School I think so
you know I think so and I was so
powerful you know it's I mean everybody
loves a redemption story you know as
part of why you're sitting here you know
we we love somebody who's coming back
you know and and the ability to kind of
own that past and shine a light on it is
the ultimate way to you know kind of
drain it of all its shame power well I
was in the middle of it that yeah so it
wasn't like I was you know I understood
it as a story arc you know I was I was
in the midst of it and and on any given
day it was just overwhelming right and
was just putting one foot in front of
the other harder than law school much
harder than you asked was interesting
yeah well so you get out and you find
yourself at a church right I become a
pastor or a reverend like how how does
all that I don't understand well there
was a I had been working in Bridgeport
for a while and I developed a
relationship with a pastor in an
all-black Church black Baptist Church
and I knew I needed an excitable on
Baptist fire and brimstone
a wire like the whole thing not Southern
Baptist but their own brand and I I went
to him and I said I asked him if he if
there was a place for me and I knew him
pretty well at that point and he made a
place for me and Lynne and I were the
only white people in the church and it
was beautiful beautiful people and but
waning you know like a lot of those
urban churches are you know it was a a
sanctuary that could fit 600 people
probably and none any given Sunday there
were 40 mm-hmm 50 maybe and so it was uh
it was an awakening as to church polity
in church what are ways to work in a
church and to actually be pastor role
and I was developing a prison ministry
at that point and I was on the preaching
rotation and doing all the worship that
you know that I'd experienced some of in
Divinity School but certainly now it was
on the ground then it was happening and
and when I would preach land my wife she
would she would go outside under the
overpass and we speak to the homeless
people in estimate they wanted to come
in to church and they would make the she
would negotiate with them because they
wanted things like a blanket you know or
jacket they were called and she said
come into church and we'll get will get
you that stuff and and she brought them
into the church and are all sitting in
the back row when she came up to me cuz
I was I was preaching that day and she
told me that she had you know bartered
with them she was making and she needed
blankets and coats and I said to her
where we're gonna get that this church
is poor this church has nothing but we
lived in Greenwich mm-hmm
so that's when we started making the
rounds of the churches in Greenwich and
and getting resources for the people in
Bridgeport well it's beautiful yeah and
so how long did how long did you do that
for two years
mm-hmm and at the same time I was doing
that I had been asked to join the board
of of a criminal justice nonprofit which
was an amazing experience because you
know this was I I knew that I was yeah I
felt accepted and so I was a I was a
formerly incarcerated person on a board
of directors of a major nonprofit in and
I was helping guys in Greenwich through
AAA who were on their way to prison or
coming home from prison and and that's
where I was kind of known as the prime
guy and there were I would say over the
10 years I did that I don't know maybe a
hundred guys I had helped and these were
captains of industry I mean these were
you know some of them you read about
this is where I feel like you really
find your your your your calling right
you become the go-to guy for her so
please Greenwich who got in trouble
who's headed to prison or somebody who
recently got out of prison and it's
trying to figure out how they're gonna
live in the world again and you're the
man with experience so a lot of you know
people knocking on your door for for
advice and this becomes not just a
calling but you sort of institutionalize
this you start this progressive prison
ministries company that's now really the
focus of what you do
trying to be a helping hand to people
who have found themselves in your
predicament well I got a call from a
reporter at a hedge fund magazine and he
and he asked me if I was the minister
was I the minister to hedge funders
uh-huh yeah I said that um the truth I
said while ministering in Bridgeport and
I'm working in recovery with hedge
funders and yeah in Greenwich but those
two concepts have never merged and he
said one is ones more interesting to the
press than the other one one's a little
more click Beatty are they love the
white collars yeah yeah and it's really
interesting what you've done in this
world and we should say like at the
outset there's definitely a sympathy
issue here you're a guy and Greenwich
there's lots of big-time money dudes
hedge fund guy private equity investment
bankers you know all those kinds of
people they get into trouble they're
looking at jail time you know it's hard
it's it's like you know okay so what do
we you know cry me a river for these
guys yeah but I've learned a lot
researching you and hearing you speak
about the realities of what happens not
just to these individuals but all the
people that are in the wake of these
offences yeah so walk me through that so
we can better understand this whole
dynamic um well just at that point I I
didn't really know what we were gonna do
I didn't understand it other than I knew
that there was a a constituency of
people out there who weren't being
served at all because I hadn't been
served and I knew from my experience in
working with them in a so we uh so we
went to the biggest church in Greenwich
and who we knew the pastor there we knew
the rector and we said listen we had
this crazy idea to become a white-collar
ministry and it's never been done before
and we don't even know if we could work
we have no idea and he said
to us well it's intriguing and and and I
and explain to him I believe that
there's there everywhere especially in a
place like Greenwich or dairy an or New
Canaan or and they're living in
isolation and they're living behind
closed blinds and their families are
affected in there and and we knew at
that point that they were being asked to
leave not just social clubs and and and
and country clubs and things like that
but they were asked being asked to leave
their churches and their temples and the
synagogues and their kids were being
ostracized and parents wouldn't let
their their kids play with the children
of these families as if they were
infected and I explained that and what
what the rector said to me was listen
why don't you go do your research go
take this on the road and see what's out
there and come back to me because I need
an institutional support for this to
happen and for the next year year and a
half we hit the road and we preached
then hit conferences and and it was
amazing the response and the big turning
point moment was at the Nantucket
project so that's why my heart is there
you got asked to speak I got asked to
speak your story yeah and so it was the
first time out of the a room that I
would have ever actually told the whole
story right in a public forum and I was
scared to death I was scared to death
and and but you'd shared your story a
million times and closed groups right
you think it would help you think it
would be the same but it wasn't it
wasn't at all the same and also I mean
you know that you developed kind of a an
a banter kind of a way of communicating
you know it's and and when I got up on
the stage I got brought to my knees I
mean I was it was an experience like I'd
never had like a lightning bolt
there was none of the banter there was
none of the pithy myths there was none
of the making people laugh a little bit
it was raw it was raw I was shaking like
a leaf and I spoke there
well you spoke there this this past year
but this is what it was like two years
ago when you were when you've not no
this is 2013 oh well and and I couldn't
hear a pin drop no I mean the audience
was was there was not one there was no
feedback whatsoever and I became aware
of that and I was scared and at the end
of it where had finally gotten through
the whole story there was a standing
ovation which I don't remember
I only the only way I knew was from the
from the tape afterwards and then here
was the the pivotal moment because now
there's I was on the first night I was
in between Steve Case and a blind boy
who sang Christian songs in perfect
pitch so it was like I was between them
of one of five speakers the first night
and the next three days we walked around
and and rich I'm telling you a hundred
people came up and hugged us and thanked
us and told us they're a a day counts
and told us about their relatives and
their children who rehab in and that's
and and we went back to our hotel room
and Lynn and I looked each other and
said what's going on like the
conversation that people want to have is
no one's having it and somehow we gave
them permission to talk about their the
frailty and talk about their issues in a
you know in a way outside of you know
outside of anything we've it and never
experienced other than in a room well
true emotional vulnerability is the
ultimate connective tissue yeah that's
true you know and I think when you get
up there and you allow yourself to be
that raw and on
and honest people know that you know and
and it resonates with people and and it
becomes that thing that you're so scared
of that ultimately becomes your greatest
strength and asset oh it was Liberty
yeah yeah and and but I I it was a
turning point you know was a moment that
I knew that I had to do this this was
this information oh yeah for sure yeah
yeah so you start helping not only you
know the underprivileged community in
Bridgeport but also the well-heeled in
Greenwich it's this bizarre dichotomy oh
my god
and we talked when we talked last you
were kind of sharing with me you know
some some aspects of of what that's like
and and I read something also that kind
of filled in that colored between the
lines for me on this which is in the
underprivileged community when a member
of that community is arrested for let's
say a drug offense or something like
that the community congeals around that
individual and that family and shows up
to support them before during and after
in the white collar well-heeled context
it's quite the opposite it's immediate
oestrus as that otra ostracization how
do you say that and like you just said
everyone flees
no one wants anyone to anything to do
with these people and you're left with
families that are you know a shell of
what they used to be with spouses who
are unable to pay the bills you know
have to go on Food Stamp like all these
things that you don't really think about
or consider without any community
support yeah whatsoever so as much as
it's easy to you know not be sympathetic
to offenders of this nature there is
real damaging consequences that extend
beyond that individuals bad behavior
well also because we've been influenced
by the media to paint everyone with this
very broad brush
an overwhelming majority of people who
are prosecuted for white-collar crimes
are are not the big name sensationalized
the story is that you that you read
about in in the paper or you see on on
CNBC I mean they're kind of just normal
people who've were desperate or or or
addicted or have mental health problems
or something went wrong and they found
themselves at that tipping point and I
would say the great commonality of the
great commonality is that it's mostly
guys so I'll just talk about it as a
male thing that they they didn't have
the the core character or ego strength
to walk into the bedroom and say to
their wives look I'm not the man I
thought I was or I'm not capable of
doing the things that we thought I was
so what we should do is we should
simplify you know sell the house sell
the cars simplify and the reason they
they don't do it and this is reported by
maybe 95 percent of the guys I've worked
with a huge number um it's because they
were afraid their wives we're gonna
leave them and and mostly because they
spent a long time lying and not being a
partner and and being emotionally
distant you know oh yeah you know
overworking and being emotionally
distant and they were afraid that their
wives without the money that there was
nothing left there and their wives were
gonna leave them and what we found out
as we progressed in this in this
ministry was that most of the wives
would have liked nothing better than to
have the husband who they married 10
years before to have apologized and just
said you know this I've been on this
this train that that that left the
station and and I can't do it anymore
yeah it's heartbreaking it is harder
than that yeah or it's a context in
which the water just it's brought to a
boil at such a slow rate that it's
imperceptible what's happening until
it's too late
I had to death but I mean like I asked
you if you knew Tom Hardin timber axe
and you're like of course I was like
really the four longtime listeners of
this podcast you'll remember that he
came on the show it must be four or five
years ago at this point infamously known
as the most prolific FBI informant in
securities fraud history here a guy who
crossed the line made some trades he
shouldn't have made got a tap on the
shoulder said getting the back of the
suburban and was faced with the prospect
of prison or becoming a dutiful
informant for the government which he
was more than happy to do he fulfilled
that role and his work culminated in the
arrest and prosecution of like a litany
of them big-time high rollers hmm but he
suffered the consequences of being you
know when he was sentenced everybody
knew there was tipper accident when you
knew who that was when he was sentenced
his name became publicly known and that
ostracization took place you know
swiftly in his family and I was able to
get him on and share his story for the
first time really in a long-form public
format and while he was in the midst of
grappling with what he was going to do
with his life and if you go back and
listen to that I'll share on the show
notes that you know a link to that
episode and it's one of my most favorite
episode because he's so raw and honest
yeah and you can hear the desperation in
his voice and the confusion because he
hadn't he was not figured out at that
point what he was gonna do no he was
very unclear he was new he was he was a
new be brand new yeah and I shared this
story with you and I'm gonna do it here
just because I I don't know that I've
ever publicly said this about I think it
was a year ago I was in New York I was
giving a talk
at a big investment bank that had
brought me out to give a speech and they
assure me into this theater amphitheater
and they said oh the people that are you
know there's a little panel going on
right now they're almost done and then
you'll go up and I open the door and I
looked at the panel and it was Tom
Hardin on stage sharing his story of
what he went through with a group of
traders private equity people investment
bankers in the hopes of sparing them the
pain that he had suffered and the
transgressions and I just thought what a
beautiful incredible full-circle moment
to be able to bear witness to that after
the experience that I had had with him
initially and I think his experience
perfectly in captures the kind of
characters that you're you know of
service to but also a success story and
that he's found a way to take this shame
and everything that he's gone through
and channel it for the betterment of
other people yeah the the times
definitely involved in the cautionary
tale aspect of it and trying to prevent
things from happening or people from
behaving in ways that are ultimately
self-destructive because all of this is
really about self sabotage you know just
trying to relieve ourselves of some
inner demons somehow and people just
blow the orange you know that's so out
of check yeah just I can't fathom that
you'll ever be caught that your
experience is gonna be different yeah
yeah exactly and so what's it like when
you're dealing with these families and
these individuals um you know what I've
learned what I've learned through this
mostly is that when I was in AAA I was I
did a lot of 12-step work a lot of
service work and what I've learned is
that the Maya a concept of service has
really changed because it's not so much
me trying to help anyone what it is is
radically sharing my journey with them
and inviting them into the the emergence
of my own authenticity and hopefully
that gives them the the the license and
the permission the agency to do that for
themselves and so there's very little
filter right now between what I go
through and what I experience and what
I'm willing to share with anybody who's
going through it
and and that could be um difficult for
them because I'm telling them the truth
and but there's something it's really
about the healing it's there and because
until someone you know this until
someone practices acceptance is
surrender and that kind of that kind of
honesty they're just not there those
lives just aren't going to get better
but to be told from the outset with
compassion and empathy and kindness that
that your life has value and that this
isn't the end
but what we're gonna do here is we're
gonna we're gonna we're going to get
real we're going to get real and that's
been and I do that by finding real
mm-hmm right by just being an example of
that mostly provides a space and gives
permission for that person to follow in
suit as opposed to look here's what you
need to do here are the five things like
doesn't work right now but the power and
just sharing your experience and owning
it a hundred percent mmm get people a
sense of hope that if they can do that
then they can have a transformative
experience as well and that I mean
that's what we're talking about the work
that you do with you know the
underprivileged community and
Bridgehampton and also this bridge port
bridge portage Hampton yeah that's even
more high - yeah yeah that was it
there we go they're very different
communities and Greenwich right so but
these are lessons and principles
applicable to anybody the young would
counsel through hardship and and that's
happened because the there's no question
i that that we came to the realization
that everybody everybody is going
through some kind of difficult
life-altering experience whether it be a
death of a child or cancer or or a
divorce or or career death or whatever
it is and that these principles are are
universal and and that we can help a lot
of people through and so there's a few
things that we got to figure out along
the way and that that the things that we
were most afraid of were really probably
the things that were best for us and
that this transformative moment is kind
of in the middle you know it's a it's a
liminal place where we're guys coming
home from prison for basically a refugee
status yeah it's not the it's not the
the end it's the it's the beginning
really yeah but there's got to be a time
period there where you're practicing
acceptance and surrender and hopefully
no longer mourning the past or
anticipating the future but this is
about my my my yet my development my my
healing right now and where does
forgiveness live in this liminal space
that's a hard one you know because
there's forgiveness and then there's
self forgiveness and I had to overcome a
lot of denial to really start to parse
out forgiveness and because I'd heard a
lot of people and I only became aware of
the level of people that I heard
by working with so many other men and it
became obvious to me about them that
they had hurt people but all of this
work is self-reflective so I started to
understand that I I hurt I hurt my
ex-wife I hurt my wife I hurt my kids I
hurt my community I hurt everybody
and with that level of acceptance and
certainly being involved in a faith
community that is about forgiveness I
started to forgive myself
and and felt forgiven that's a big deal
is there a difference between acceptance
and self forgiveness um like they're
pretty close they're pretty close yeah
they're pretty close I mean I'm excited
for me it's acceptance of the reality so
the reality was where I was living at
that in in that moment I mean it was
there was the fantasy had been broken
right but to move to probably higher
orders of acceptance and compassion and
empathy those moves took a long time it
took a long time what do you think is
the hardest part of this arc of healing
that hamstrings the most people that you
work with that there we are prisoners of
our own making you know it's it's a
strange thing you know we're not what I
when I started this the world was very
different politically and economically
and and then the criminal justice
conversation has developed in the last
ten years to the point where it's a it's
a it's dinner table conversation but
we've gotten to the point now where
where companies and and institutions
will accept people who've been to prison
and
maybe it's driven by I don't know under
4% unemployment and they need the help I
don't know if there's a lot of factors
but the biggest single problem that that
we have in matching people who come home
to prison and then end the jobs for
example is that people come home from
prison including white-collar don't have
the ability to emerge they're there
they're there in these tight prison
cocoons and they're and they're trapped
and so can't even get to job interviews
don't have the self-awareness of I mean
the imagine the amount of capacity that
is lost of tens of thousands of people
who have advanced degrees and have so
much experience and and they're driving
uber over there they're working in
construction and and so much of that
it's about the their own making and can
you find the opportunity in the
dismantling I mean obviously you know I
would imagine you look back and you have
some gratitude for these experiences
that were you know on paper quite tragic
and challenging and difficult to
navigate but you now live a life that I
would presume is much more fulfilling
than the life you were living before
yeah I'm right I didn't know way of know
so to be able to kind of navigate that
treacherous landscape from there to here
is really the goal and you know when I
when I kind of canvas when you when you
scale up and look at it from 10,000 feet
it's as much a social problem as
anything else like we're in a time right
now where you know we Harold the
billionaire like we never have before we
put a purported one in office and and
this is the ideal the manifestation of
the American Dream and so we've created
institutions that funnel young people
into systems that lead them to believe
the billionaire dream is possible for
them they become perhaps worn out by
those systems and then cut corners
because they're still adhering to this
idea that they could be that person and
end up on the wrong side of the law with
that but what's driving all of this you
know it's ego it's greed it's our
consumerist culture it's the it's a it's
a crisis of values and ethics that is
fomenting what's beneath all of this
right and as somebody who now lives in a
spiritual place how do you think about
cultural mores and and how we can raise
the collective consciousness of society
and culture at large to you know be a
prophylactic against this kind of thing
even happening to begin with well that's
the big idea and there's no question
that it can't be just about being on the
road and telling cautionary tales to
business school students and and
prospective lawyers and hoping that 1%
of that information will get through you
know the there's there's got to be a
radical shift but the things we honor
are really is strange because you know
we might think that we honor the
billionaire for example or we honor the
rich and famous but underneath it all
this is a deep sense of schadenfreude
you know where we're waiting for them to
fail we want them to fail and and so
there's this you know the you know the
devil is not far from the door you know
the there's a sickness involved in it
and and so you know we so do we do we do
we really love Justin Bieber or do we
love the fact that you know he's in the
back of a squad car having been arrested
and and and I'm involved in you know in
the various stages of that with people
it's one of the reasons why we've lost
well for us at first it's the it's the
reason why
um I accepted the job at family ran tree
you know um you know about three years
ago or so I was on the board of
directors there and they asked me to
become the executive director and CEO of
that organization and which ended about
three weeks ago but I would I was the
first person who had been incarcerated
for white-collar crime in the country to
be made the head of a major criminal
justice organization so that's not the
first person has been to prison that's
the first white-collar criminal and that
was a that was a big move I mean it was
a bold move for the board of directors
but I accepted the job because I wanted
to I wanted to be able to say that you
know the we can be trusted that we can
be in positions of respect and authority
and and that we don't have to live in
shame and thinks that was the theory
yeah and whether or not I've helped them
move the needle even one degree I don't
know I mean that the proof will be in
the pudding for that but the
conversation out there has certainly
shifted and there was a time when I
couldn't get invited to any parties and
Greenwich for example I mean I was a
pariah and and then there was a time
where I was a I was a you know a an
interesting story you know or you know I
was a you know I was the way where do
you hear what Jeff has to say or I was
the you know I I was I was already
trapped here the token party trainer for
sure yeah but I don't feel that way
anymore
you know and and and I'm certainly
invited now to things that I wouldn't
have been been divided to in the past
and and I'm walking erect and with my
head held high and so a lot of okay so
it's Tom hardened you know there's a
perfect
example yeah and and because we don't
have to live in it
and and what does this mean more broadly
in terms of trying to change our culture
well I mean a work culture that at one
point in our history I believe held
basic character issues in high regard
certainly ethics and and and morality
were at the center of our university
system I mean the first colleges in the
country were seminaries and somewhere in
the middle of the last century we
abdicated that kind of training to
professional schools and then for
example the business schools created
something called business ethics I don't
even know what that means so how do we
find our way back
um I think it's happening I think it's
happening I think that do you think it's
happening as a reaction oh yeah yeah oh
yeah for sure I mean I think that people
are much more aware and and I think that
there's a few things going on at once I
think there is a call back into
character and and values and used to see
it even in people's lives I mean the 20
years ago dads weren't coming home to
play soccer you know to the coach soccer
but now you see a whole a whole backlash
I think back there's probably the wrong
word but you see new a new generation of
people who are reinvested in their
families in a different way and it's
certainly one of the reasons why what
we've taken on kind of a what we'll call
a epical rehab approach and so it's it's
for people if they're prevention and
education or or in kind of the
redemptive process or then in the
reunification of families and the
restoration of people's into whatever
their new norm is going to be but we're
providing kind of the the services that
people would
having a drug and alcohol rehab but
specifically oriented towards ethical
issues so I'm an example is you know
Tiger Woods he he has set the collapses
of his own sort right he gets chased
down the driveway by his by his wife
with the pitching wedge of the 9-iron
and he goes to his lawyer's office and
and his life is over and the lawyer says
to him well you know go to rehab and and
for he did for 90 days and when he came
out he was he'd someone who'd evidence a
willingness to go through some kind of
transformative experience and I'm not at
all interested in what his lawyer has to
say or anyone's lawyer has to say I'm
interested in the person I I want to
help people actually change and I would
love to do it before there's some kind
of precipitating event but the reality
is is that that these guys and women
when they're when they've been tapped on
the shoulder by the FBI or someone else
they are they're in survival mode yeah
it creates a heightened reality that
precipitates a willingness that
otherwise would not be found yeah and
and and and they don't even know what
kind of some game they're in at that
point you know they don't know but yeah
I think you know look rehab can be this
perfunctory stop on the PR
rehabilitation trail there are people
that find themselves in the crosshairs
of some crisis of their own making but
every once in a while it works you know
we saw it with with with Michael Phelps
sure you know it's it's effective for
certain people some people they're just
doing it to check the box so that you
know they'll be ingratiated back into
society again only time will tell
whether that's real and the only way to
know is to pay attention to people's
behavior well you know at the end of
many AAA meetings there's a line of
people with little white sheets that go
up and I know is one of those guys
I used to I used to fraudulently write
those signatures on there for the judge
yeah well so so for people who don't
know basically yet you have to you have
to document your going to meetings so
you can tell the judge yeah and and you
know for the rest of us anything that
gets you in the room is fine I mean
there's a lot of different motives to
get in the room we want to help you get
well and and so so we've taken this to a
step that's non substance abuse related
and it has all kinds of co-occurring
thing is this mental illness and there's
drug and alcohol and we're working with
different groups and people and that
this will evolve it's in its infancy but
I think that I think that what we need
is a commitment to that you know to
character and to ethics and and I
certainly search continually to become
that person I was at 12 years old before
I found my you know my first joint yeah
yeah that's beautifully put you know and
I think it's needed now more than ever
given that we have on the one hand this
massive and ever-expanding opioid crisis
and we have incredible problems with our
prison industrial complex and these two
things are colliding with each other to
really just exacerbate the problem
making it worse and you're somebody who
you know basically was at the
intersection of both of these things so
when we look at the opioid crisis I mean
do you know are you familiar in criminal
justice reform like what are those
numbers right now and staggering yet
what are we doing about this and how can
we do better well like anything else the
the resources weren't there until it
became a a finding there was a financial
incentive or a political incentive to do
it and now there's a lot of resources
being thrown at at the opioid crisis the
so-called opioid crisis because not that
there isn't one
but it's really no different than the
crack academic that there was it just is
touching a different strata of society
so it's it's it's a shame that we will
you know we we criminalize behavior that
affects the inner-city people but we
show such such empathy and compassion
for a the same kind of problem but it's
affecting people in the more affluent
communities but you know anywhere we can
get any we can get the resources I'll
take their I'll take I mean it is but
it's also I mean you know look they call
oxy hillbilly heroin like it's you know
very deleterious and a lot of yeah you
know underprivileged communities
throughout the south particularly you
know in areas like that like it's it's
touching all different demographics
yearning from the guy on like yourself
the Park Avenue guy who gets the surgery
and gets what's the Demerol down to you
know smashing up the oxy pills and you
know being stuck in your basement for
six months I last year I became the
volunteer chaplain to the fire
department in the town I live in Wow in
Connecticut uh-huh and so I had to go
through a certain amount of orientation
and so they're talking about the
different kinds of calls they go on they
go on fire calls to go on cat up a tree
calls they go on all kinds of different
calls and one of the calls that go on
are exploding meth labs and I'm in this
bucolic right you're like to having
Connecticut like you know Litchfield
Hills beautiful exploding that happens
here but you know in front of the church
on the on the hill or our crosses with
the names of all the kids from the high
school who died that year yeah so it's
it's real and what about our prison
system we're like right in the wake of
this prison isn't in the Bronx that like
lost its heat during the dog Brooklyn
Brooklyn right the heat went out
and the polar vortex yeah we got
problems here what's going on there well
it's it's subhuman conditions I mean
there was subhuman conditions before the
heat went out and it was just
exacerbated and it's terrible and I know
a lot of but I do I wasn't there but I
know a lot of people who were there who
and it's terrible and it's the
warehousing of people and it doesn't
make a difference what your what your
economic background is it's it is making
money on the backs of other people and
so we live in a culture where criminal
justice basically make fifty thousand
dollars roughly per year per person and
so just do the math if we have to point
something million people behind bars
that's the size of the that's the size
of consumer and and someone's going to
make money on it
yeah I mean is there any way out of this
privatization scenario that we find
ourselves in like can short of changing
campaign finance laws and and how
lobbyists work and all of that I don't
see this changing too much money's being
made you know my my personal theology's
is not to it was to be positive and I do
believe that there's a lot of awareness
going on but I believe that I also know
that this is a conversation that's been
going on for centuries yes maybe for
millennia and and that the advocates
will advocate and the people in power
it's truth to power
and the people in power will probably
grant little wins to people so that
their placated to appease to appease and
they'll find other ways to make the
money we have to wind this down but I
want to leave people with a place to go
and something to think about
particularly people that are listening
who
who are suffering continue to suffer or
know somebody who suffers from a drug a
substance abuse problem as somebody with
a long-term sobriety who's kind of
steeped in the traditions what do you
have to say what can you what kind of
lifeline can you throw to someone who
maybe is wrestling with this privately
and has yet to really come to terms with
the reality of their situation I I don't
mean it all for it to sound hokey or
trite but this hope and I'm I'm not
special I'm probably sure you don't view
yourself as special we've we've been
granted grace somehow and all we had to
do is show up every day and do the work
and live one day at a time and then some
higher power decide to what our fate was
so if it could work for us it could work
for anybody and I don't take it for
granted for a day because the us is
today tomorrow it's going to have its
own you know its own issues and I trust
I'll be sober tomorrow but maybe not you
know maybe not but if there's anyone out
there who who thinks that it's
impossible or thinks they're so
desperately in the throes of their
addiction or their problems or whatever
and the answer is just like when I sat
at my desk and I had a stack of files or
a stack of paper how do you get through
it and the answer is start at the top
mm-hmm and that's what this is about
just turning myself over hurting anyone
turning themselves over to things that
they don't know about and that's okay as
dark as the prison of your own design
may appear or feel to you I assure you
and I promise you that there is oh just
like you said that there is a light
available to you and I say that you know
not to be trite as you mentioned but
only because I've seen this transpire
and thousands of people men over the
years people coming from circumstances
and situations
so dire that it's actually mind-blowing
the extent to which they've been able to
turn their lives around
yeah so I implore anybody out there
who's listening who has a sense that
they may have a problem please reach out
for help there is help available to you
if you do not want to drink or use again
you do not have to but you've got to
raise your hand you've got to make your
voice known seek out help in your area
there are plenty of resources I'll link
some of my preferred resources in the
show notes to this episode and please
take advantage of them because you're
worth it and the world needs you to be
the best version of who you are which is
sober and conscious amen to that
right on yeah thank you I really I
appreciate the work that you do it's
beautiful actually and your story of
transformation really is quite wonderful
and amazing so I wish you the best this
is yours by the way well maybe I still
need to go to Divinity School I don't
know my mother would be happy if people
are desiring to connect with you where's
the best place for them to go online to
do that at prison Astorga so like what
minister feminist prison is org and all
the informations there and you know we
have a lot of resources a lot of content
that's valuable you do like a radio show
too
yeah we do real show yeah yeah usually I
have the I have the headphones on yeah
next time
yeah cool um thank you thank you Rick
come back again sometime thank you bless
you god bless you peace
[Music]